in den letzten Folgen haben wir erst mit
körperlicher Arbeit und dann mit AI
versucht uns den Traum vom Porsche zu
erfüllen was aber wenn das alles von
vornherein der falsche weg war und die
tiktok Gurus dieser Welt doch recht
behalten sollten viel Spaß mit einer
neuen Folge von Porsche Trailer
[Musik]
und bevor wir so richtig ins Video
starten genau in diesem Moment ist die
neue Kollektion von tarmacy Drop neue
Shirts the police Hosen ganz viele
Produkte unheimlich nice direkt unter
dem Video oder in der Videobeschreibung
zu finden von einigen Produkten sind
tatsächlich nur relativ wenig Sachen da
also seid schnell und viel Spaß dabei
und damit herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren Folge Porsche trade ab Folge 5
mittlerweile nachdem es in der letzten
Folge um 8 generated Kunst ging wird es
heute um echte Kunst gehen und zu einem
Update das AI Videos kommt es im
nächsten Video ich sag mal so viel es
gab direkt nach dem Video ein zwei
kleine Problemchen aber wir hoffen dass
wir das lösen können ich habe in der
letzten Zeit immer mal wieder tiktoks
vorgeschlagen bekommen in denen mir
erzählt wurde wie leicht ist doch sei
mit einem winning Produkt Geld über
einen eigenen Dropshipping Store über
irgendwelche Online Stores oder sie zu
verdienen und heute schauen wir ob es
tatsächlich so ist probieren damit
reicht so kann wirklich jeder zum
Millionär werden drei Möglichkeiten als
tiktok auf viel Geld zu verdienen
werde mal Reich auf Social Media tummeln
sich eine Menge Leute die nur darauf
warten Geld auszugeben wenn man ihnen
das richtige Produkt zeigt tiktok
Instagram wheels und Youtube Shorts sind
eine unheimlich krasse Möglichkeit eine
Menge Leute zu erreichen und das
kostenlos mit ziemlich geringem Aufwand
man muss nur den Content machen
problematisch an der Sache man kann
jetzt nicht super Zielgruppen genau
Dinge platzieren und Content machen
gegen Bezahlung wiederum bieten all
diese Plattform eine Möglichkeit sehr
genau die Leute zu erreichen die die
Produkte interessiert und zwar durch
Werbung ob Bewerbung kaufen müssen oder
wir mit original content schon die
richtigen Kunden erreichen können wird
sich noch zeigen wir probieren es
natürlich zu vermeiden als allererstes
brauchen wir einen winning was dieses
Produkt aber ist weiß ich selber noch
nicht deswegen Schritt 1 tik tok Shorts
für Inspiration durchschauen bis wir was
passiert
grundsätzlich haben wir sowas wie drei
Optionen und das ist Punkt eins
Dropshipping wer hätte es gedacht Amazon
FBA und drei print on demand
Dropshipping fällt direkt raus Leute
müssen lange auf ihre Produkte warten es
ist rechtlich nicht ganz einfach
irgendwie ist es alles nicht so auf dem
customer zugeschnitten das ist eine
geile customer satisfaction hat Punkt
zwei Amazon FBA grundsätzlich mega geil
man kauft irgendein Produkt schickt es
bei Amazon ins Lager und die kümmern
sich um alles was es zu tun gibt mega
geil für den Customer mega scheiße für
uns weil wir müssen im Vorleistung gehen
und dazu kommt dass ich bei allem was
Amazon anbietet permanent bin vielleicht
erinnert ihr euch an das Video indem ich
versucht habe mit Amazon viele Geld zu
verdienen und das sehr gut funktioniert
hat und ich dann gesperrt wurde also
fällt diese Option auch raus option 3
print on demand jemand bestellt ein
Produkt und nur wenn er diese Bestellung
absetzt wird dieses Produkt auch
produziert Problem wir haben kleinere
Magen gut aber die Produkte sind sehr
schnell da wir können einige
verschiedene Produkte anbieten von
Textilprodukten also T-Shirts Hoodies
ist zu passenden Postern und so weiter
und warum ich mich für Poster
entschieden habe das seht ihr jetzt ich
meiner Website gefunden dropship io die
scheinbar uns die sales von Shops
anzeigen kann oder eine Schätzung
abgeben kann die ziemlich gut ist wie
das funktioniert ob das legal ist keine
Ahnung und nach dieser ganzen Recherche
jetzt ist ein print on demand Poster
Shop glaube ich das Beste was wir machen
können ich habe auf tiktok einen Typen
mit dem Namen twentoster gefunden der
Prinz in alle verschiedenen Richtungen
Sneaker Rapper Autos und so weiter
verkaufen und nicht nur sind seine
eigenen tiktoks super viral gegangen
nein wenn wir dieser Website wirklich
vertrauen können hat er in den letzten
30 Tagen 77000
$ Umsatz gemacht nicht deswegen jetzt
100 % Rippen wollen aber wir nehmen
seine Idee und probieren Sie zu
verfeinern probieren mehr Poster in die
Richtung zu bauen von dem Postern die
wirklich gut funktioniert ich denke dass
das die beste Option sein wird wir
müssen Poster produzieren print on
demand an Ben tiktox produzieren Werbung
schalten und Werbung Tage und wir müssen
weiter solche Wolf of wall Street
Ansagen machen hier die Leute dazu
auffordern jetzt richtig Kohle zu
verdienen Multi Level Marketing nur wenn
wir in einem Schrank ziehen wird das
Schritt 1 Poster gestalten bei unserem
Vorbild 24 Poster sind die Rap related
Prince mit Abstand die Bestseller
außerdem brauchen wir aber noch Motive
aus anderen Nischen wie Sneaker Auto
Einrichtung also Bauhaus oder sowas
Schauspieler Legenden Filme Kunst
minimalistische gradients und so weiter
also erstmal Design was das Zeug hält
und all diese Arbeit also auch alles
abseits von Postern gestalten wie Shop
bauen tiktok produzieren schneiden und
bearbeiten findet auf meinem MSI Stealth
Studio statt mit einem i7 der 13
Generation eine Nvidia RTX 4070 und 32
Gigabyte RAM habe ich so immer und
überall genug Power ins Licht im Design
den meisten von euch wird MSI als einer
der führenden Entwickler und Hersteller
von IT Produkten Edition ein Begriff
sein für die Leute die aber noch nicht
wissen was MSI ausmacht erzähle ich es
euch jetzt obwohl MSI häufig und das
auch richtigerweise mit Gaming in
Verbindung gebracht wird haben sie auch
unheimlich viele super leistungsstarke
Rechner für kreative Anwendungsbereiche
im genau sowas was wir hier machen und
natürlich ist das Ganze nicht nur
schwarz und weiß denn auch auf der Step
Studio Reihe lässt sich anständig in
höchster Auflösung von egal wo zocken
egal ob von zu Hause oder unterwegs
diese Laptops verbinden also höchste
Gaming Power mit sleek im Design und
maximaler Mobilität also egal für
welchen Anwendungsbereich ihren neuen
Laptops sucht ob Gaming die Uni oder
Kreativarbeit diese Laptops Vereinen das
Beste aus allen Welten in einem Gerät
kleiner seit Effekt einer der drei
katter des seven vs Welpens hat den
gesamten Prozess auf genauso einem
Laptop bestritten und das tadellos ohne
Probleme nicht zuletzt weil der Laptop
in Videos Studio zertifiziert ist was
uns Hardware und Software seitlich durch
Treiber in jedem Kreativprozess das
Maximum an Leistung daran ich kann also
voller Überzeugung sagen Check die MSI
Produkte über den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung aus vielen Dank an MSI
fürs möglich machen dieses Projekt ist
und euch viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video
insgesamt habe ich knapp 100 Prince
gestaltet wir brauchen aber noch einen
Ort an dem ich diese Poster dann auch
anbieten kann im Prinzip sollte es so
einfach wie genial sein klicken uns hier
durch und erstellen einen shopify Store
müssen wir uns Namen über legen den ich
euch natürlich nicht nennen kann damit
ihr nicht wisst und ich die Reichweite
nicht nutze und genau damit starten wir
jetzt
[Musik]
Shop eröffnen sich durchklicken Account
eintragen fertig Testversion startet
Shop steht können uns um print on demand
kümmern ich habe das Gefühl dass der
andere Shop Gelato benutzt weil er
bietet mit Rahmen und ohne Rahmen an
okay mit Gelato können wir
kleiderkalender Wand Kunst das ist was
wir suchen Poster mit Holzrahmen im
Prinzip alles was wir wollen
wie möchtest du Bestellung importieren
und verarbeiten automatisch alle
zukünftigen Bestellungen automatisch in
Gelato importieren Bestellung
automatisch an die Produktion sind heißt
so viel wie wenn es wirklich
funktioniert jemand bestellt bei mir die
Informationen gehen automatisch weiter
an die Personen die printet und ich
hoffe die kann man sich um alle
Rechtssachen und Datenschutz und so
weiter und der voll Filter das druckt
das und schickt das an die Person also
ist krank die haben eine komplette App
gebaut die so funktioniert und wenn ich
das richtig im Gefühl habe werden wir
gleich das Produkt automatisch was wir
jetzt gerade hier einfach so hin und her
ziehen in dem Shop hinzufügen können ach
du scheiße
die App von Gelato die wir gerade
hinzugefügt haben macht alles wir laden
das Foto hoch die erstellt uns
automatisiert Produktbilder sie gibt uns
die Produktkosten an und wir können den
Preis bestimmen und wir können quasi
sofort verkaufen das war wirklich eine
Sache von 2 Minuten jetzt wenn wir auf
den Online-Shop gehen und hier
reinschauen sollte jetzt sofort das
Produkt an
ja wir bekommen das Produkt so fort
angezeigt das ist komplett geisteskrank
der Shop steht wir haben Designs wir
haben den Shop aber wir haben noch keine
Kunden deswegen heißt es jetzt tiktoks
produzieren ab in den Baumarkt ein Haken
kaufen Test Prinz bei der Druckerei um
die Ecke holen und tiktoks produzieren
Test sind da sehr schönes Format und von
jedem Thema dann so ein zwei Bilder
jetzt kannst in die Produktion der
tiktoks gehen und im Prinzip zu dem
entscheidenden Punkt an dem wir
verkaufen indem wir Leute davon
überzeugen bei uns Geld für Poster
auszugeben genau das machen wir jetzt in
guter tiktok man natürlich auf dem Handy
damit das möglichst nativ wird dann die
ersten gedruckten Poster da und wenn das
jetzt hinten so ein bisschen umgestellt
und das ist scheiße aussieht ohne Bild
und dann mit unserem sehr günstigen
Postern die auf Poster Master Shop
24.com zu kaufen sind diese Fläche
schöner zu machen jetzt probieren wir so
viel Material zusammen wie es geht aus
der Hand Film wie wir das ein Rahmen an
die Wand hängen und dann wirklich
richtig Content raus ballern zu können
so das wirklich wir am Tag so drei Stück
raushauen können damit wir möglichst
viel Potenzial haben dass irgendwas
davon viral geht ohne dass wir es
bewerben müssen und natürlich werden wir
dann danach auch noch probieren
nachzuhelfen mit ein bisschen Kohle
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Digger das ist ja Übelkeit no Joker da
würde ich selber kaufen das Ding ist
halt realtalk so Poster machen das
Zimmer halt Ernst viel geiler und man
macht das nicht man druckt sich einfach
selber keine Bilder so einfach auf
tiktok so eine Möglichkeit zu bekommen
du siehst das Video und dann braucht es
drei Klicks dass du no Joggen richtig
geiles Poster fertig im Rahmen zu Hause
kommt ist ernst Übelkeit ich habe jetzt
gerade eben halt mit Geisteskranke Idee
gehabt weiß ich nicht in wie weit wir
die jetzt noch umgesetzt bekommen wir
müssen es schaffen dass diese tiktoks
organisch abgeben klar werden jetzt
coole Poster wenn coole Videos gemacht
ne aber es ist trotzdem noch immer ein
tiktok dass wir für den Verkauf von
Produkten machen also dass das viral
geht ist unwahrscheinlicher als
irgendwas was ohne irgendeiner
Verkaufsabsicht passiert jetzt habe ich
gerade eben die Idee gehabt gibt es
einen Bot der automatisch tiktok
Kommentare scannt und dann etwas machen
kann so dass wir im Video sagen können
folgt diesem Kanal liked das Video und
kommentiert welches dein Lieblingsposter
ist und bekomme automatisch einen 50%
discount code per DM geschickt das ist
wirklich komplett geisteskrank ich
konnte alles einstellen ich habe unser
tik tok-profil zu einem Business Profil
gemacht was uns die Möglichkeit gibt in
tik tok selber in der App ohne
irgendeinem bot personalisierte
Nachrichten automatisiert zu versenden
am Ende der Videos sagen wir jetzt immer
markiere zwei Freunde like und Folge für
20% Rabatt und schick uns eine kurze
Nachricht und erhalte sofort ein 20%
Code für unseren Shop durch das Technik
machen wir neue Kundenakquise auf
unserem Kanal interagieren in allen
verschiedenen Möglichkeiten und wir
triggern weiter Käufe weil wir 20 %
Codes geben das ist das Trio der Hölle
wenn das tatsächlich funktioniert und
das alles automatisiert in der tik tok
App ohne bot
vollautomatisierte Nachrichten das ist
komplett geisteskrank also eigentlich
muss das Funktionieren genau in diesem
Moment nehme ich das Passwort zum Shop
raus was bedeutet genau jetzt ist der
Shop für alle zugänglich jetzt heißt es
Leute auf die Plattform bekommen dafür
haben wir das erste hoch
[Musik]
es ist getan tiktok muss für uns
arbeiten im besten Fall ohne dass wir es
noch mal bewerben und dann kriegen es
hoffentlich hin dass das wirklich
funktioniert und wir damit ordentlich
Kohle verdienen können als allererstes
jetzt während das tiktok im Hintergrund
arbeitet zeige ich euch einmal die
Früchte unserer Arbeit den gesamten Shop
wenn wir die URL eingeben landen wir auf
unserem Shop in einem kleines Logo
gebaut und wir haben außer Home und alle
poster-seite gar nicht darunter noch mal
die Beschreibung das gerade Sale ist da
kann man auf shoppenau drücken sehen
alle Poster und darunter Kategorien wenn
wir also nur für Auto Poster gekommen
sind können wir das Anklicken dazu haben
wir bei jedem Produkten Vergleichspreis
hinzugefügt so dass überall die sale
Markierung kommt wenn man über die
Produkte fährt havanni Bilder so also es
fühlt sich wirklich gut und es liegt an
auf dem Rechner aber auch auf dem Handy
und das ist natürlich am wichtigsten
weil die Leute kommen von tiktok und
werden im Zweifelsfall übers Handy
shoppen wenn man sich für ein Post
entschieden hat sehen wir hier noch mal
den Vergleichspreis wir können die
verschiedenen Größen auswählen wir
können mit und ohne Rahmen bestellen das
wird dann auch dementsprechend angezeigt
mal echt eine Menge Aufwand aber es
macht unheimlich viel Laune super viel
kreativer Kram der echt für mich mein
größtes Hobby ist jetzt hoffen wir dass
wir verkaufen und reich werden der Shop
steht der Shop läuft die tiktoks sind
online aber zu welchem Preis eigentlich
sind wir ziemlich gut mit sehr wenig
Geld ausgekommen shopify kostenlose
Testversion shopify Apps kostenlose
Testversion Gelato bezahlen wir nur oder
bezahlen die Kunden nur wenn sie
tatsächlich irgendwas kaufen und deren
gesamte Software und so ist auch
kostenlos wofür wir aber Geld ausgegeben
haben sind rahmenhaken und Testdrucke
Rahmen mit 24 € Testdruck mit 18 €.
Haken mit 3 € macht einen Preis von 45
€, die wir jetzt im Vorleistung gegangen
sind Werbung haben wir erstmal nicht
geschaltet wir probieren und hoffen
erstmal mit organischen Content
irgendwie klar zu kommen und ein paar
erste sales zu machen dazu aber mehr im
nächsten Video in dem wir hoffentlich
diesen Shop auf Maximum skalieren also
vergiss nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
vergessen nicht abzuschecken vielen Dank
an MSI fürs unterstützen Sie dieses
Videos wir sehen uns in den nächsten
Tagen wieder